and we are continuing our conversations
with
luminaries in science philosophy the
arts
conversations that expand our mind our
awareness
and give us an opportunity to question
our habitual certainties i'm certainly
guilty
of that i've been guilty of
habitual certainty all my life so i
start with that conviction confession we
are here
principally to have a conversation with
three uh
influencers in the world of science and
physics
uh first frank wilcheck who's a nobel
laureate you'll see all his
credentials and you'll see a link to his
book which is
absolutely fascinating we have brian
keating
who's also a cosmologist very involved
in the
original experiments looking for
gravitational waves
and we have my friend leonard melodna
who i met
at caltech on a debate with
skeptics like michael schumer and others
but we ended up being amazing friends
and leonard has written two books with
stephen hawking
and has also coded in a book with me
talking about the different perspectives
regarding science and what we call
spirituality
but spirituality is a loaded world and
we have to be careful how we uh use that
word and we'll come to it in a moment
but this conversation that we're having
was initiated by brian keating
brian is a very significant cosmologist
physicist i've
known him for a while i think we met uh
together
here at some of the conferences in in
san diego with roger penrose and other
people so
brian you initiated this tell us why
well uh thank you so much deepak it's
good to see my friends uh
all gathered around we won't team up on
you deepak don't worry
it's not going to be it's not going to
be a physics intervention where we try
to convert you
to become a physicist like us uh but
uh in reality i feel like the the the
environment that we're in now
is a very dangerous one for society as
science loses some of its you know
prestige perhaps or we believe that
debate is impossible in the political
sphere
and that seeps into the scientific
sphere making it impossible for people
perhaps people of faith perhaps not uh
to debate scientific and philosophical
questions with
comity with friendship this is uh this
is what i wanted to
to arrange because i think there's
really no better interlocutor
than you deepak to take these different
world views
as you and leonard are fond of saying
and try to find some committee between
them
uh not for the sake of conciliants just
so for its own sake
but for actually doing good for the
world around us and i felt like
uh these uh these these gentlemen frank
and leonard
are two uh eminent scientists that i
look up to and have learned a lot from
and also i'm not afraid to debate with
me as long as it's done
civilly and i think that's my goal ryan
uh we need to come to your book as well
losing the
nobel prize because we
that's right now we talked about that
when frank was on my podcast uh the into
the impossible podcast which i run from
the arthur c clarke center
but let's start with dr
uh wheelchair may i call you frank sir
yes of course uh so frank you know a
while back
science magazine published
the 125 open questions in science
and the first one was what is the
universe
made of and the second one was
what's the biological basis of
consciousness
and i stopped right there because you
know the rest of the questions
i think depend on the first two
questions
what's the universe made of and what's
the biological basis of consciousness
or is there a biological basement
consciousness
and so i was fascinated by your book
which is called fundamentals and
it's an extraordinary book i spent the
weekend reading it
very carefully and i learned a lot there
was a lot that i knew
thanks to leonard you know and
leonard and i have had a good
relationship over many years so
there was a lot there that i did
understand there's a lot there that i
did not understand
but here's the question that i have for
you
right off the bat and it's your question
in a way
what do we know of the physical world
what is the world made of because
my understanding is only you know
that there might be two trillion
galaxies out there
two trillion yeah there might be
seven hundred six zillion stars out
there
there might be uncountable trillions of
planets out there
and that may be less than one percent of
the visible universe so what's the
universe made of
well at a fundamental level the universe
is made out of space time and quantum
fields
and there that uh
is a very rich structure from which you
can make a lot of things
the sort of things you mentioned
so but fundamentally there are very few
concepts
that uh we can boil down the description
of the world too
and that's an extraordinary statement
and an extraordinary achievement
i i read that the world is made of
space-time
and matter but you also said um
fears and then you said dynamic
complexity
what do you mean by dynamic complexity
from
from these ingredients you can make
dynamic complexity which is a way of
representing
and processing information so those are
emergent
concepts that uh just as from
lego bricks you can make extraordinary
structures
and uh if you supply them with motors
you can make
even more extraordinary factories
from a few ingredients put together that
have the right properties
fortunately you uh you can make
stable but not too stable arrangements
of matter
that allow us to have patterns that
have can be interpreted as patterns of
information
and that have a useful stability and a
useful regularity
that support different kinds of objects
that you mentioned stars
planets but also uh humans
individuals animals and and so forth
so the world is made of forest fields
particles vehicles as some people call
them
and why does it look like this why does
it look like you mean
and everything else that we're looking
at right now
well that's that's a tough job that we
have as physicists to show how from
these very uh abstract concepts that
we've
boiled it down to that you can
reconstruct the world
it uh it's been a remarkable journey
from democritus who talked about
uh atoms in the void as opposed to
warm cold uh
the taste of different kinds uh he
he had the vision that that actually the
the fundamental part the description of
the world was something quite different
and uh ever since we've been learning
that lesson deeper and deeper we've been
trying to get a more and more compact
description and and now we have
for practical purposes i believe a
complete description of how matter works
and you could put it all into a computer
program and teach it to a computer
that and the program would be shorter
than say the program and
less complicated than say the program
for word because
the basic principles are very very
simple however they
in that profound sense in that very
precise and profound sense you could
teach it to a computer without loss
uh however the uh world is so abundant
in terms of how many copies of these
structures it has and supports
and these structures are so rich
in the ways they can combine
and function with each other that
we don't see any barrier to making the
world we see around us
out of those ingredients and you don't
have to take my word for it
you know we're speaking at the moment
from uh
at great distance over computers made of
transistors that were designed
using quantum mechanical principles and
uh carrot and the information is carried
by waves that propagate through space
according to maxwell's equations
it really works and
and uh that so that
so we've we've in in fundamental physics
we've been on a journey now
for uh close to 600 years to boil down
to description shorter and shorter
that that's what we try to do we do
analysis to get
the most basic equations and then
synthesis to build things back up
and both both part both
of those directions are important
directions for science
and we've done i think in
culminating in the 20th century the late
20th century we've done an extraordinary
job of analysis
and now our big challenge is mainly
synthesis
there are there are loose ends in the
description
to put it mildly of fundamentals
i think you've alluded to the fact that
if you consider the universe by mass
the kind of matter that we really
understand deeply
is only about five percent of the mass
of the universe
and there are other ingredients called
dark matter and dark energy
about which we know a few scattered
facts
but we don't have a really uh precise
description worthy of standing besides
our description of other elements of
matter
uh and the universe of those things
and the five percent that you refer to
most of it
99.9 of it is
invisible interstellar dust mostly
hydrogen
helium so the actual visible universe
is well no even that well there are two
kinds of of dark matter
there's there's dark matter made out of
the stuff we know about which is not so
mysterious and that's
as you say distributed in gas clouds and
things that are just
hard but not but hard to detect but
modern astronomy is
pretty good at seeing signals from those
things
and then there's some other component
that's about
six times as much so the kind of matter
we understand really deeply that's the
subject of biology and chemistry and
all forms of engineering made out of
quarks
gluons photons and electrons we
understand deeply
uh that's about five percent of the
universe by mass
and then there's something called dark
matter that
we're not sure what it is i think i know
but
uh the evidence is not really
fully in place uh that that makes up
about 30 of the universe by mass
and then there's something called dark
energy which
is uh still quite mysterious but
we know the equations it satisfies but
we really don't have an
intimate knowledge or even an intimate
guess of what it's made out of
so doctor witcher you said something
very interesting right now
we know that this works we are having
this conversation
yes you and i are speaking millions of
people
might be watching us again we hope to
reach
15 million let's have your book a little
more prominently displayed
again look at the ten keys to reality
so uh leonard and i were once speaking
in sweden
at the same place where you got your
nobel prize
and i mentioned that
science is very effective but
is it getting us closer to truth and
there was somebody right in the front
seat
who said dr chopra how did you get here
i said i took a plane you took
you trust your life with science and yet
you say is it getting us closer to truth
and you know he got a standing ovation
just for
remark so you know this brings me to my
second question
which is something that leonard and i
talk
about a lot can mind emerge
from matter and so
i'd like both your opinion on that
leonard's opinion and brian's opinion on
that
um i think certainly certain kinds of
mind can emerge from matter we know that
uh my computer will beat me at chess
sometimes and and the best computers
will beat the best humans at chess
or go or many things that were thought
to be
fundamental indications of mind and
intelligence
now we know can emerge from matter
because we designed them that way
and the domain of things that our
machines can do
is expanding very rapidly exponentially
as
we speak and the artificial intelligence
is
catching up with natural intelligence on
many fronts and there's no question that
that's emerged from matter because
we know exactly how it works we've
designed it
uh from the ground up using quantum
mechanics
uh and the uh
now there's another question which is
whether the
the minds that humans have that we sort
of
experience by introspection and by
interaction with other humans whether
those are really emergent properties of
matter
and there we don't have a complete
understanding by any means
but i think the program that dominates
neurophysiology
is to assume yes that it does and
so far there haven't been any show
stoppers aft you know with
years of more and more detailed
investigations
of how memories are stored how memories
are laid down
how the different electrical signals
within chemical signals within the brain
and the rest of the nervous system
are propagated how uh simple
uh nervous systems and simpler animals
work
that there we can understand almost at
the molecular level
uh so all those indicate
uh that uh
the substrate the material substrate of
of mind
is matter as we know it and that
this doesn't detract from mind it
enhances
what matter uh can do we understand its
potentials
much better and one more thing i would
add about that
is uh when physicists do
experiments they
have to be very careful now with modern
delicate experiments
that measure say the position of mirrors
to within
in in the case of the ligo gravitational
wave detector
to within one one one ten thousandth of
the
diameter of an atomic nucleus uh
and do and we do many other
extraordinary things like
measure uh time with an
accuracy of one second per lifetime of
the universe with atomic clocks
and compare them and they so people have
to make all kinds of
corrections and precautions for
temperature
for vibration isolation
for getting a very good vacuum for
making sure that the
things are very cold so so that they're
not
thermally excited but one thing that
people have never had to correct for
is people what what what people in the
in the lab next door are thinking
there's never been any demonstration
in these very uh precise delicate
experiments
of any uh
ability of mind to control matter
so that's a very powerful constraint on
to me on the idea that there's something
other
than a property of matter involved in
the phenomena we call mind
okay so you know for the last four years
i've been engaged
in creating an ai version of myself
and it's going to be released in three
weeks
it's called digital debug right so we
had
we had a demonstration of it with
wall street journal and the journalist
asked
my ar version what did you eat for
breakfast
and he said i don't eat breakfast
and i i don't eat breakfast i don't feel
hunger
i don't have sexual urges i don't fear
death
um so i'm talking about that kind of
mind you know that has
subjectivity imbued in it
longings aspiration creativity
um vision insight inspiration
intuition uh reflection contemplation
meditation all the things that you talk
about in your business
and i i don't see her mind or
you know i also have a practice at night
where i
do a meditation where i look
recapitulate my life
i look at myself as a boy as a child
as a teenager i can't identify with
those people
you know they're like ephemeral
memories
and i have a very hard time convincing
myself
that my self-reflection is the
interaction of force fields and gravity
and vehicles and particles i want to be
convinced of that
but i keep asking myself who is having
these experiences
what is questioning this and can a
machine
or matter ever experience subjectivity
now of course my body is made of matter
and i'm experiencing it but who's the i
that experiences what i call my body
that's a different question we might
come to that
in the end but i want to go to leonard
right now because
what you raised the only thing the only
thing i would say in response is don't
underestimate
matter
we know that matter can do some very
surprising things
yeah i want to come to that because you
know i also want to
quote from your book which there's
something
very interesting we are big enough
specifically to contain the entire
universe
in our minds and elsewhere you say
i'm large i contain multitudes
who is your favorite daughter of mine i
was also thinking of rumi the super boy
who says look at your eyes they're so
small and they see enormous
things yes because i am so small
how can the whole universe be in me so
i want to go to leonard right now
because you know he was so close to
stephen hawking who was physically
quite handicapped and yet his mind
explored the far reaches of the universe
going all the way
to singularities and black holes and
hawking radiation and all that
so is uh leonard
please comment on what dr wilczyk has
just said can matter create mind
what's your opinion i agree with frank
and i think he said it quite well and uh
you know there's
uh never been a any evidence
in all the history of science uh of of
any
effect or forces uh of the mind that
that are not attributable to physical
forces
and i think that as a scientist uh
hopefully we are all open-minded enough
that if something some evidence would
come up that we would uh
we would uh investigate that and and
theorize about it and accept it
but uh in the absence of that even
though there are many mysteries in the
universe there's mysteries of what is
dark energy there's mysteries of
who am i as you say right and who's
experiencing this phone call and who
likes you deepak
who loves you where does that come from
i don't know but because i don't know
doesn't mean that i
you know attributed to something beyond
the what i've so far observed i just
don't understand
how how it is and i would like to make
one other point that came to me as you
were talking and frank was talking which
is um
my friend uh christophe cough um
who i used to know very well back at cal
tech uh he
he's uh does neuroscience research into
uh
consciousness as you know i know you
know him and um
and he told me long ago when i was
thinking of writing my book subliminal
on the unconscious mind
that that when a scientist studies the
unconscious it's much different than
when
people you know philosophers or people
outside of science study the unconscious
because
we have to operationalize it and we have
to study very specific concrete
well-defined questions
so when he studies the unconscious he's
studying he studies the visual system
of the brain and how your brain through
different layers processes information
as you know very well deepak the the the
photon the data the optical data that
hits your retina is not what you
experience and it
it goes through many different layers of
processing and your brain is really
constructing reality
your experience of reality from that
data but it's not a an accurate uh
reflection of of that data that's why we
have for example optical illusions and
things like that
um and so when a scientist studies
consciousness we are there are
scientists who are interested in it
we're
we're not it's you know decades ago it
was considered a uh
a taboo subject i think kind of
crackpots would study it but now i think
it's it's taken seriously but we
we do it very slowly step by step by
understanding how the neurons in the
brain work how
different very specific phenomena in the
brain occur
and we try to get at it piece by piece
step by step and probably
is going to take another you know
decades and centuries perhaps before we
understand it but that's
that's our approach and when something's
a mystery
uh you know we we we approach it but we
we do it step by step in a very
methodical
uh reductionist manner i know we don't
like that word
um not that we don't look for emergence
because i don't like the word
reductionist but
but um but we looked at it we like to
say in a systematic and very
well-defined manner using methods that
we know um
make it hard for a harder for us to be
full
than if we uh just the ordinary person
uh
contemplating that's great
and uh we've discussed this before
and many times brian
any comments on uh what has been said so
far
i should mention we are talking about dr
wilczyk's book
fundamentals 10 keys to reality please
look it up we'll have a link to that
to amazon and other linked to
leonard's book which is a memoir of his
relationship
with stephen hawking and a link to brian
keating's book
on why he didn't get the nobel prize
i did get it uh frank left his when he
came to visit me
okay now uh yeah what do you say to this
moment so far because i want to move on
to something
yeah the only thing i want to add is
will checks varmints
okay yeah i i had a little bit of a
taste of that conversation with frank
and
i also talked with noam chomsky over the
uh over the summer here's i've got
finger puppets of all my guests so we're
working on one of of leonard and uh
frank's on the way but
the thing that concerns me after talking
to so many people in the last year
eminent uh scientists and and thought
leaders so to speak
is that we seem to be really obsessed
with this notion of artificial
intelligence and it seems like a
reductive
way that we want to simulate the
imitation game the kind of
approach that turing suggested back you
know can machines think
which i remind you he came to a
conclusion that that's a meaningless
question
and he felt it sort of uh you know
analogous to like you know do airplanes
fly
you know the question of what is the
essence of
of an operation especially when you're
trying to apply to the human mind so my
my thing nowadays you've heard of the
hard problem of consciousness
and artificial intelligence i'm more
interested in
artificial wisdom is it possible for for
wisdom to be produced
uh because i think that's the none of
being a human being
i think that's what makes us individuals
i think that's why there
aren't you know 30 different there are
30 different types of of great primates
in the world but but nothing
like a human being and so from my
perspective i'm more interested you know
kind of
in this in this notion of the hard
problem of wisdom where does the where
is the origin
of wisdom where does it come from in a
human being i actually
deepak and i spoke with noam chomsky and
roger penrose
uh two years ago here in uh in in uh san
diego when
stewart hameroff organized his
conference about cutting the science of
consciousness
and i came away depressed from that in a
sense because
they can't even agree of electrons or
frank's beloved quarks that
that he has done so much with if they're
conscious
and and to me a field you know in that
state it left me depressed
except when i started to realize that we
are the only creatures that we know that
have
real sense of wisdom and so that's what
i'm more concerned with
that's great you know i was reading
frank's book
and i have to say first of all
congratulations on the book it's
brilliant
and it raises more questions
than ever before and one of the
questions
is of course can the human mind the
human brain
does it have the capacity to actually
even know
what fundamental truth is and so when
i was uh you know just now leonard
mentioned christophe [ __ ] and
you know christophe [ __ ] of course
worked with
francis craig whom you quote dr wilczy
yes in the book as the astonishing
hypothesis
which is that mind emerges from matter
basically that mind emerges from matter
now one of the other
students of francis craig
was john hoffman with whom i've been
having many many many conversations
and don hoffman was actually charged
by francis craig to prove the
astonishing hypothesis
which he struggled with he's a cognitive
and perceptual
scientist he finally gave up he said you
know
to believe this with the astonishing
hypothesis
is to believe in alleged lamp you you
put you kind of scratch this thing
which is this which is the consistency
of jello and suddenly
it opens up the universe for you so he
finally actually
has given up on the astonishing
hypothesis
and he's now writing about the case
against
reality where he says that even
space-time
are emergent they're not real and that
matter
is a human construct for modes of
knowing
and experience of human perceptions
and so when i was reading a book i
actually came across
this passage where you talk about your
grandchildren
it's beautiful because you say that your
grandchild
is actually intellectually constructing
the physical world
absolutely what did you mean by that
well
babies are confronted with a big problem
when they
are born they uh
are not wired up and
they get raw sense impressions of the
world which
are uh very confused and very confusing
they the electrical signals that arrive
in our brains
or uh the the impulses of light that
arrive
arrive at our retinas are
very very far from uh
the three-dimensional world that we try
to make out of them we have to
take that information find patterns
process it interpret it as
objects uh learn implicitly
geometry and do all kinds of things
learn
the distinction between self and not
self and or
many many uh very difficult things
that we still don't know how to
implement really
in artificial intelligence uh
in order to make a usable world to go to
be able to interpret those sense
impressions
as a three-dimensional space with
regularities and other peoples
and some parts that are us in some parts
that are not us
this is a very uh constructive difficult
process and clearly
babies children humans in general even
adults don't understand
uh how they do it or exactly how it
works
we have not been able to teach machines
how to do it although
we're making progress on that
and it's underdetermined in a way and
i'm sure evolution gives us some help
by doing some pre-wiring but
we use all kinds of rules of thumb and
uh experience do if you've ever watched
a baby you know they drop
food over and over again or through
uh and do do these kinds of frustrating
experiments that
tire out the adults but the baby finds
them endlessly fascinating because
they're learning how the world works
and a baby's constructing the physical
world
constructing a model of the physical
world the part of the physical world
what we do in science is great models
are we closer to truth
or are we constructing models well we
have much better models
in an objective sense is that they allow
us to accomplish
much more and describe a much wider
range of phenomena
accurately so we don't rely
only on our senses but on telescopes and
microscopes and magnetometers and
accelerators and all kinds of tools
uh and demand an uh
a description that's consistent with
everything those
tools reveal so it's closer to truth
but as as you've alluded to uh
it's an endless process i think because
we we're as
we've done very well on the analysis
side
i think in culminating in the in the
late 20th century with what's called the
standard model or i like to call the
core theory
which seems to be a very complete theory
of matter for practical purposes
with a very wide definition of what
practical means but
the prostate uh
process of going from there to
describing
more complicated objects even more
complicated molecules that we want to
use for drugs
let alone uh human beings or brains
is an ongoing process and we uh
the question then that's that's i think
is
isn't uh an open-ended process oh yes
there it is is there a matter of
constructing models of matter
yes matter is constructing magnets of
water
yes can we ever create something
completely abenitio frank or len in your
opinion can we
physicists create something that has
never existed before and it's the old
question is is math discovered or
invented
do we actually invent rather than a
model actually physically creating
something have an issue
well it depends what your standards are
but
let me give you an example that is dear
to my heart
that really uh bore fruit
in there in the recent past almost 40
years ago now
i was thinking about fundamental uh
principles of quantum mechanics and how
they might be generalized
and for many years since the discovery
of quantum mechanics over about 50 years
so modern quantum mechanics people
thought that
the all the possibilities for how
particles
could behave were limited to two
something called fermions or something
called bosons
but in the early 80s i realized there's
a wide variety of other possibilities
called anions
that would be possible for
emergent particles within matter and
in 1984 we've made a
convincing theory i think of how they
could emerge in certain states of matter
but it's taken 40 years and then finally
last spring uh
after many improvements and materials
and techniques and
people finally found it you know and
then
that without the original concepts
there's no way you could blunder your
way
into that and it's fundamentally new i
think by
most standards of what fundamental means
what fundamentally new means and uh yeah
it came from
it it was thought that became embodied
in reality
i have a more uh prosaic example or
maybe a more poetic example
i created uh two children
and they're unique they're new they
never existed before
yeah but not ab initio i guess there's
the old joke you know scientists says
scientists says to god i can do anything
you can do god says oh yeah can you make
a man
out of dirt the scientist says sure just
get me some dirt
says no no get your own dirt you know
the joke being that you know
those are materials there beforehand of
course yeah something out of the vacuum
is that what you're asking
well i just mean you know like like yeah
creating is it possible
you know that's that matter is so deepak
asked frank
do we create the universe does a baby
create the universe and frank answered
properly
no the baby is constructing a model of
the universe but he's not actually
constructing a universe there are people
who say
we can make a big bang or a black hole
in a laboratory
in that sense do you guys believe that
there's evidence for such things
well what kind of big one even or i mean
i think if you made it
whatever it i mean you're creating a new
university laboratory is that was that
what they mean
some claim this some claim yeah you
could create a black hole that would
swallow up certain well but when you
make a black hole that swallows the
earth or cern or
you know that why is that something from
nothing
i don't well i think i i think asking
for something from nothing
is uh is asking a lot
and maybe and maybe actually although
it's a grammatical sentence may not be
something that actually makes sense when
you
analyze uh the meaning of the words uh
however i think a more fruitful
question is whether you can get out more
than you put in
in sense of uh you start with
ingredients that don't have a lot of
structure or complexity and kind of
can't do much
and you end up with an iphone and
yes you can definitely do that if we do
it
right i guess yeah i mean i'm thinking
of the inverse i i think it's all we'd
all agree you can destroy
thing you can destroy matter right i
mean you can annihilate it you can't
destroy energy
but you can destroy matter and in the
sense that frank you pull up
you know uh asymptotic freedom i mean
you could explain that
you're basically shielding and nature is
invisible at some level to our gaze but
but i think the inverse of destruction
and that's what i worry about with the
vast tools you know carl sagan said
you know whether or not we have the
wisdom to handle the technology
that our knowledge has produced that is
the key question that's a big question
indeed
and uh uh
it's not a settled question well when
you say brian can you create some i mean
the knowledge optimal things that
by do you mean uh what do you mean by
that
uh i mean you always have something that
you start with even you know
i have what what i as a baby developed
as my own
world i have the math that i learned i
may have some some i may create a new
theory of physics or
asymptotic freedom as frank did but but
but i starting from something
right um what does it mean to start from
nothing
that the moment a baby is born before
any
sensual input even before the baby was
born was essential and put in the womb
when the baby is like eight molecules or
has never
experienced any part of the world can it
create i mean what
can it create so first of all i think we
have to give credit to our wives for
doing the hard work and creating the
baby okay
i was present for a few minutes i
believe at a certain moment but uh
but yes something that is truly never
you know it's this old question
is math invented or discovered and are
you know this difference between
uh as i said well that's a different
question though because invented versus
discovered
is a question of whether you you feel
that uh you know the universe has some
inherent
principles that you're discovering or
whether this is a math is a tool that
the human brain is inventing
but what you asked before was can you
get something from nothing so
does that i mean does that mean if i
never you know
before math was there somebody
babylonian i don't know invented what we
might call the first math
sumerian but but that's not even coming
from nothing because that person had
experience of the world and knowledge of
of of the world and had some basis of
which to make that jump
so i'm not sure if it as frank said it's
a well-defined question to say
well yeah i guess i'm riffing off what
detox said you know can you create is a
model of the world the same as creating
the world or
i do believe that it's possible for us
to destroy the world right i mean we can
destroy things that said
so is there is it a ratchet is it a
one-way unidirectional
process or does it have symmetry in time
and frank's you know
is it a time crystal in some sense we
okay let me tell you what we can do okay
let me introduce oh go ahead go ahead
oh what well we can produce
things that in a sense you could
consider
worlds if your standards are low enough
i mean in materials
we can create uh
homes for particles and homes for
behaviors that
are very different from what we find in
the world as we know it so the
things with emergent properties that are
very different like anions but
also uh computers in general
that the uh or uh smart materials that
do things that
uh are not natural in the sense you
don't find in the natural world and we
we can design them and in that sense
we're making worlds
uh and i think as time goes on the
things we can make are more and more
impressive
and i don't think it's impossible i
think
in fact i think it's very possible and
maybe inevitable
that we can make worlds that house
intelligences you know intelligent you
know some people would say we've already
done that with
with computers that beat us at chess and
so but but uh
but but have a more general kind of
intelligence and this this would be
embodied within
uh some form of electronics or maybe a
quantum computer
the the in any way in any case a
physical object that's quite different
from anything you find in the natural
world
and it's not making something from
nothing
but it's making i don't know in some
sense
more from less or taking
concepts and using them to make to
coax matter to do things that that
we didn't know it could do and
there's a famous uh i think the third
law
of arthur c clarke is that any
sufficiently advanced
technology look is indistinguishable
from magic
and i think that's certainly true if you
took uh
someone even from 100 years ago and
brought them to today and showed them
around
they think it was magic or
certainly they'd see that things that
they couldn't begin to understand
and wow instagram
and i would be very surprised if a
hundred years from now that's
also that's still the case though we
could if we went forward we would see
things that
uh we would uh that our minds would be
properly boggled
right that's well my mind is already
boggled
i've been at it now for 50 minutes
and i had guessed we would be speaking
for approximately an
hour but before we go to the next
question that i have for all of you
uh let's uh look at all the books uh
because uh
that's the purpose inform 15 million
people out there
that are very important discussions so
frank can we look at your book
fundamentals
details i happen to have a copy here and
we
will be linking the book leonard your
book
what inspired you to write this book
and tell us a few words about your
relationship with stephen
well um steven contacted me
uh about 2003 and uh he had read
my first couple books and uh asked if i
he was looking for someone to write with
and someone who understood physics and
uh who's
writing he liked and i was certainly
blessed and honored to
that he asked me and uh through our work
first what we did was we rewrote a brief
history of time to make it uh
simpler and clearer really uh that
became a briefer history of time so it's
like a new edition and then
uh he used to visit caltech for about a
month every year and
uh i was on the faculty there and i saw
when he came by the next time after that
book was published i
gave him a proposal and i said why don't
we write a book about your your new work
because all his other books were always
about his work that he did in the 70s
and 80s and he i thought he was doing
fascinating things
in the 2000s and that took about five
years and so we
we worked together closely that became
the book the grand design
and got to be friends and uh
i have to say it was one of the most
inspiring or moving um
life-changing things that ever happened
to me to to have that association with
him because he was
such a special individual partly
obviously because of his grit and his
iron will to to overcome
his disability uh where he all you know
had to work so hard
uh just to get words out and couldn't
move or take care of himself
and yet he had a tremendous outlook and
sense of humor
but but also because um as a human as a
person he had an amazing
quality which is i think very important
to satisfaction and happiness
in life and to thriving in life and that
was a sense of purpose
uh he i think in his younger years
in undergraduate he he was floating and
he was kind of a goof off and he was
a brilliant guy but but didn't have any
particular thing he wanted to do and
when he got sick he realized that
uh or he decided that there were some
questions that he wanted to answer about
the universe
and that's how did the universe begin
and why are the laws of nature
what they are and he decided then that
he would
dedicate what he thought was his last
couple years to
to pursuing that and that became decades
and decades of that
and i think that really drove him and
that gave him his um
joy of living and his you know looking
forward to being up each day and to
attacking these problems and to
working with other people and and how
they were uh
looking at it and that and and i and
that was an inspiration to me because i
um
you know i feel that i have a i i found
that as well
in science um and in as he did in
popularizing science
and so he he really showed me how
um you know the stoic philosophy ancient
stoic philosophy that
that you're and it's not far from your
philosophy deepak that
that your your your happiness your
satisfaction your
your um joy or in in life comes from
within that that that you should
that that it's good if it's not material
things that drive you or even even other
people
it's it's good to have good relations
with other people but really uh
what what you are comes from within
yourself and when you have that
then other things that happen to you
don't don't disturb you if they're
where they might disturb you otherwise
and i i've certainly learned that from
you as well deepak you are
you know about the most um calm
and peaceful person uh
that i've met and we've gone through you
know different periods of things
happening and then you're always just a
rock and you're always
smiling meditating you know so that i
have to say that's
pretty amazing too and um so i was lucky
enough to have both of you guys in my
life and to
be kept become enriched by it
so what i have to say is that
because of you i had the good fortune to
meet stephen hawking
um in new york when he was flown over
for his 70th birthday we watched that
ballet
called icarus it's about this kid who
skirts a black hole
and gets lost in interest in that space
and ends up in a different galaxy
and when he ends up in that galaxy they
say oh what what
spaceship is that that model went out of
fashion about a few billion years ago so
you know that was an amazing play and
i'm grateful to you that i've met steven
because of you brian has been
an inspiration to me because he
questions
my habitual certainties and
i think this conversation that we've
just had we could go on forever
and possibly we should before we
we conclude one of the most interesting
parts of frank's book
was his take on complementarity
yes and i found that very refreshing
because
i have worked with maynard kapatos who
also
trained at mit a long time ago leonard
knows him
and manas has three principles when he
talks about
laws you know the laws of nature one is
universality whatever is here
is everywhere the second is
complementarity
but the third you might not like is
creative interactivity and the reason i
bring that up
is you talk in your book
about mass spin
and charge as the most fundamental
properties of magic
yes yes yes yes okay and then you also
say
and i'm i'm going to read from your book
i hope i can find it you say
modern fundamental ingredients of matter
mass spin charge have no intrinsic
size or shape they are structureless
points
where mass spin and charge reside
so are they material entities
well by definition that's what matter is
and as we've discussed uh now
in different forms several times uh
it's a big challenge to
get to climb back up so we do
analysis to uh understand the most basic
ingredients of matter
and they turn out to be these very
strange things very unfamiliar things
the mass been in charge located at
points or
you can in the spirit of complementarity
you can also look at in other ways as
quantum fields
uh and
now then there's the great task of going
from those concepts
to explain how
the the more visible aspects of the
world
uh arise and this is the process of
analysis
and synthesis and it's a wonderful
process that's been fantastically
successful
so doctor wilche for a common person
like me i'm not a physicist i
don't understand the math but for a
common person
matter is physical
it's something that i can touch i can
grasp
that's energy in charge don't seem to be
physical entities but they give rise
to physical structures that we
look at including our own bodies could
you would you be sympathetic
just sympathetic to the idea that mass
charge
and spin are actually principles
and and processes
that govern the interactivity
of certain very fundamental laws
that ultimately give rise to the
experience of what we call
matter yes well i think that's an
accurate description of how they
actually work
okay well then in that case
phd has been granted now you have an mit
phd
okay well in that case i'm going to
conclude our talk so the point
of these concepts is that they go
together with rules for how you use them
very precise rules for how you use them
and
those those rules are things that govern
how more tangible aspects of matter
uh emerge so that's absolutely got it i
totally understood
so i'm gonna just ask you a few
questions yes
respond yes or no and
feel free lena and brian to interject
since we talk about complementarity a
space and time
complementarities
uh no space time is a unity of the two
and i don't know of any useful way in
which you can regard space and time as
complementary
uh that you know complementarity in
general
is the idea that you can describe the
same thing in different ways
uh so space and time
are are not that in sense they're not
complementary they're in
a way they're almost the same thing uh
but in other ways
they're different uh so
yeah i mean so the answer
to your question of yes or no is a
complimentary
complimentary answer is yes and no
both depending on how you exactly pose
it
that's very quantum yes and no so
in my mind space time wave particle
mass energy body mind biological
organism
world appearance conscious subconscious
science philosophy you mentioned
humility and philosophy
you want humility and self-respect i
think
that's the most important yeah are all
complementarities in my mind
because they're different ways of
looking at the same entity
i agree with goals and i and i and i
disagree with others
but in general i think uh the more ways
you can look at something
and use those viewpoints to ask to
answer
important questions about that something
uh the better off you are
and that's our free will and determinism
complementarities
absolutely they are complementary
because we
experience free will and free will
is a necessary ingredient of the law
and the moral codes but on the other
hand
determinism is built into the equations
of how we describe
matter very profoundly and if you
ask other kinds of questions about us
since we're made out of matter uh you
will get determined answers
well i don't agree i i i think that free
will
and determinism are an opposition no so
they're not describing the same thing i
think that if you believe in determinism
uh then there is no free will there is
only an illusion of free will
no i i disagree with that that that's um
i believe you do that's that's the
result i think of a much too narrow
conception of what free will means
and if you don't i mean if if you don't
believe
in free will how could you have laws
that uh
how could how how do you make a
distinction between sanity and insanity
i mean
well those are all look the distinct
between insanity and insanity are you
know whatever
artificial i mean uh according to
according to the law yeah
guilt and innocence yeah it's a prime
minister right
right the big thing the big bang made me
do it the big bang
okay if you knew the uh the exact state
of the person
uh at a given time and the laws of
physics apply and as you
said yourself you don't believe anything
outside the law of physics applies to
the brain
then you would be able to to predict in
principle what what the brain is going
to do
yes but all those are big ifs
uh first of all quantum mechanics tells
you you can't
well i don't want to say if i'm not
saying that that that you have to
stimulate that i'm saying that
that that um if for what you say to be
true
then this what we call is of free will
because we don't know how the brain is
doing the calculation so it seems like
it's free will
but if physics really governs the
physical world
100 with no exceptions then to know
everything that there is physically
about the brain would allow me to
predict the state of the brain at a
later time
which would allow me to predict its
actions if i could do the calculations
now free will is the word wait wait
let me just finish we will i call an
effective theory because it's the word
we give to it because we can't do that
and we can't do the calculations so
it's the illusion of free will because
we're not capable of predicting what the
system is going to do in the future
no but in principle because we're
talking principle
in principle there is no free will it's
only in practice that we seem to have
free will
okay and then what what
frank is saying is quantum uncertainty
actually
says that there are problems no no no no
no no
that's that's that's dangerous ground no
what i'm saying is okay so let's
that i'm saying that free will is a
concept that stands on its own that is
extremely useful and absolutely
necessary
i agree if you're dealing with uh your
own
experience or in the with the law or
with many moral concepts
so it's a concept we need saying it's an
illusion
uh does not is i think
very wrong because it's not an illusion
it's a thing that really applies
in the world in very concrete
circumstances and
we can discuss why it's a useful uh uh
concept from debate from on the basis of
uh even though uh the underlying
description
at some level is using determinate
equations uh first of all
we don't we so if you had a complete
description of the human
being you could predict their behavior
but you can't have a complete
description
we can't we can't get the weight it's
not just a matter of practicality we
can't the
wave function has much too much
structure if you measure it you lose
that structure
and even if and then there are severe
practical problems in calculating the
behavior of any complex
uh object even in classical mechanics
there's
uh sensitivity to initial conditions
sometimes called chaos
uh and that's a practical problem that's
so severe that it's
it's a problem of principle because it
would take you
so much time and so many resources to
calculate how something behaves
that uh you would use up the entire
universe
and all its time and always and you need
to know that you can't
actually do it you also need to know the
way
so we need in practice we need concepts
then this is the essence of
complementarity you need
alternative concepts in order to
describe the world
and won't do this i'm not saying that
they're not useful
you don't need them to describe the
world just like your brain calculates as
you said earlier
yeah an illusion it may it creates
a reality for you from the data that
comes to your eyes so i agree with all
that
but what's dangerous about talking about
fuel the way you're doing it
is is the the people who don't
understand physics
who think that the randomness of the
wave function
and and the different ways in a way he
didn't say that he said he said the
interactions with them
please let me just different ways that
the wave function can be measured those
different outcomes
when you attach them to free will it
seems like our decisions that might be
based on good and evil
somehow are not are being determined by
the physics
and and what i'm saying is all that is
determined by the equations
we can't predict what the outcome of the
equations are
and yes when you measure something
quantum mechanically you can get
different answers with different
probabilities but those are totally
independent and have nothing to do
with what we think of as the decisions
of humans such as good and evil and
things like that so we have to be really
careful
when you use that kind of test well
misunderstanding and any in any
application of complementarity and this
is one
you have to uh treat the different sides
on their in within their own context and
within their own domain
and applying the idea that
uh human beings are determinate and
there's nothing you can do
because it's the way you were born it's
your way function uh
would make a mess of the law and
morality
and and on the other hand
uh saying that mind can affect matter
and and you can by wishing make it so
and do faith healing i think those
also are very wrong so you you when
you're
when you apply complementarity you have
to be
uh you have to be true to the
uh to the idea that different concepts
are important for answering different
kinds of questions
and neither one exhausts the full
reality
ryan any last comments from you before i
have the last word
yeah i just say that i have to believe
in free will because i have no other
choice
thank you guys that was really fun no no
no don't go i want to have the last word
and then i want everyone to maybe
comment
maybe if you want to but i do want to
have the last word right now
because first of all i want to say that
this was a very illuminating
conversation for me
i continue to learn from all of you
dr wilczyk quoted
wittgenstein in his book see frank i
read your book
read every sentence wittgenstein
is a favorite philosopher of mine and
also you know i've been a fan of
schrodinger
and his uh interest in the origins of
life
and uh right now we are in in a very
interesting
phase of questioning everything
including
darwinian evolution here we are
this is the latest issue of uh
not the latest but a new issue of
science a new scientist
which questions some of the dogmas of uh
you know random mutations in natural
selection
so we're in a very interesting time but
it was wittgenstein who said in one of
his
essays our life is a dream we are asleep
but once in a while we wake up enough to
know
that we are dreaming so i come from a
tradition
i come from a tradition which is the
exact
opposite of
what we've been discussing what we've
been discussing is matter
as the ontological primitive of the
universe
and that's an assumption you have to
start with an assumption anything starts
with an assumption
so matter is the ontological primitive
of the universe
is the way we do science and it works no
question
about it that's right didn't have to
work no it it predicts the outcomes of
experiments
let's say that and it creates technology
which saves our lives and so on
but also the way we've done science
we've created
climate change we've created cyber
hacking we've created extinction of
species
we've poisoned the food chain on your
weapons
and nuclear weapons and we are basically
uh on a collective suicide mission
at the moment if you don't wake up to
climate change
and all yes even the pandemic you know
we say
it's a it's a mutation but it's linked
to
the dysbiosis of the genetic information
of our planet
which is due to uh i think can be
connected to climate climate change as
well
so in any case in your book you also
mention
species specific experiences a bat
only knows the echo of ultrasound bees
navigate through ultraviolet an insect
with a hundred eyes
i don't know what it sees or what it
experiences
on and on i can look at every species
and look
at it as having a bandwidth of
experience
the human bandwidth of experience is
less than one percent of the visual
spectrum
acoustic or acoustic
no but but that you're missing an
important no no we can extend that
through instruments we can
yeah through instruments we can
but all this begins
with the mode of knowing and experience
in human consciousness
science is an activity in human
consciousness
mathematics is an activity in human
consciousness i think of mathematics as
unbelievable amazing
imagination in consciousness that
somehow corresponds
to the physical laws of nature then you
have girdles theorem
which says there are laws that can't be
proved
then you have the cosmological constant
which is way off
but then you have dark energy dark
matter
so we have lots of issues to solve now
i come from a tradition which says that
the ontological primitive
of the universe is not matter but matter
is a human construct
for modes of knowing and experience in
human consciousness
that even the brain and the body and the
physical world
are a unified experience that we
call mind brain body and universe
but in fact these are human constructs
for modes of knowing and experience only
in human consciousness
so when einstein said the moon would
still be there
was when no one was looking at it
i think he meant a human moon not the
moon of a horseshoe crab
that comes from the depths of the ocean
to the surface
lays eggs on a full bone night
and birds come to feed on it
with exact precision of ecosystems
weather patterns biological phenomena
gravitational waves the earth spinning
on its axis and hurtling through space
at thousands of miles an hour all of
this is
correlated somewhere
and therefore what we call the
scientific universe
is a totally human construct
and a very useful model that takes us
closer to truth
but what truth is
is a great mystery still well
there are many things we don't know but
there are also things there's a lot we
do know
yes but who's the weed that seeks to
know
so i would say you want us to comment
well i can speak for myself
why is the experience of a caterpillar
less legitimate uh the experience of a
human being through a human nervous
system
well i just i just wanna i would just go
back to what i've
went through at some length before which
is that
so far we've never had
to make allowances in
very very delicate experiments
for what people are thinking but i still
don't know what produces thought
what is what if that if any such effect
could be demonstrated
well would be fascinating would win
several nobel prizes
and fame and fortune uh uh
so there's an outstanding challenge uh
do it if
if you think that mine can affect matter
every time i lift my arm mind is
affecting matter
well but oh no but that that well what
we mind
yes mind is affecting matter but we can
uh we can trace how that works
mind is working through matter to do
effect
i mean right now we are having a
conversation yes
and if this conversation was scary
everybody in the world who was watching
us
the cortisol level would go up their
immune system would be compromised
if this conversation elicited awe
and wonder and joy they would make
serotonin and dopamine and all this so i
i personally feel that the distinction
between mind and matter is
actually is an artificial distinction
there are complementarities of a deeper
reality
see that could even pan psychism
psychism assumes the existence of matter
what i'm talking about says matter is
the illusion
even mind is the illusion there's a
deeper reality
that it experiences itself
as mind and matter and these are
complementarities of that deeper
realities
and we don't know what that reality is
other than mass
charge and spin mark when you say that
you raise your hand
i don't agree with that with the part
that says it's your free will that
caused your i didn't say free will it's
an intention but
your intention your intention your free
will it's not it
it's still explainable by physics but
what i agree with
and this is i think the deeper part of
what you are saying is that i i agree
with you completely
that in a sense that that i don't
say that matter charge spin is any truth
or any fundamental uh necessarily
fundamental aspect of the universe it is
a construction
of the hub these concepts and the
theories that we built from them
are constructions of the human mind that
is peculiar to the way our mind is
constructed intelligent aliens uh who
have a different kind of a mind maybe a
horseshoe crab
but but much more intelligent or a bat
could construct their theory of the
universe using completely
different concepts i believe come up
with the same
usefulness of their equations and their
predictions they would sense they would
perceive things differently
but they could have a completely
different viewpoint just as um
you know uh in physics for instance
freyman's formulation of quantum theory
is different from
heisenberg and then scrubbing his
formulation they they could have
completely different mathematics based
on different concepts that we may not be
able to comprehend that are maybe beyond
us or just different from the way well
that's just like thesaurus but if both
but but if both descriptions have the
same experimental consequences
right well they're they're equivalent
in a very in a very specific sense and
yes i think they could but they might
not they might not have anything that we
would call mass charge and spin
that's easily identifiable in their
theory well it's
not logically impossible but all i can
say is lots of luck
let me ask all of you frank
i've been reading uh sean carroll's book
something deeply hidden was its
infinite universes uh almost you know
multiverses and infinity warfare
leonard in his book uh grand design
mentioned
mtre and possibly 10 to the one of
500 universes brian i don't know what
your take is
what do you guys think of these models
i asked sean that oh sorry go ahead
frank well i think they're very
speculative
they they they are inspired by
uh physical phenomena but they
don't explain a lot and
they uh their their consequences are
rather nebulous so they are not
part of the core of our understanding of
the universe they're interesting
speculations and fun
but uh to me they're not
the center of interest in physics or our
fundamental understanding yeah i've i've
researched this a lot
in in terms of trying to find the
complementarity between
physics and faith and i found many many
faith-based statements that assume these
to be correct
including based on my conversation with
len last week
that stephen hawking sort of went to his
grave as far as i understand
believing in the veracity of m theory
for which there's currently
a complete absence of experimental data
and so i find it you know interesting
that that
in frank's book he talks about this how
uh this this
this is the interesting aspect of the
complementarity of the multitudes within
us
and the and sort of the humility that we
also have to have as manifest
through you know understanding the
limits of our knowledge but also
as i say checking your biases because we
do have this anthropomorphization
fetishization and i think i want to
particularly be on guard about that so i
am very anti-multiverse i did ask sean
i said what's the probability that that
god exists he said less than one percent
i said what's the probability that the
multiverse or the many worlds of everett
exist and he said 50 50.
by the way in the in the indian
philosophical system that i'm
talking about there's no room for
god as a person but there is room
for god as pure consciousness that
differentiates
into different laws of knowing different
modes of knowing different noise and
different
modalities known that are species
specific no one species has a privilege
to truth over the others we have the
privilege of creating better models of
the truth
i'd love to debate that from
technologies that extend our experience
of virtual reality
we are already in a virtual reality now
with technology we are
expanding that with all the wonderful
insights that you guys are supplying
i'd just like to conclude with a with a
quote from rumi
um he says if you're not bewildered by
now
go back to sleep
elsewhere he says exchange your
cleverness for bewilderment
and i think the scientific pursuit is
based on
mystery bewilderment
and if we don't have those we
our humanity is incomplete and as long
as we keep questioning
every theory of science so far has
proved to be untrue
uh every theory so far
has been found to be incomplete
and incomplete yes but as isaac asimov
said
deepak never forget what isaac asimov
said he said if you think the world
is flat you're wrong but if you think
the world is
perfectly spherical you're also wrong
but you're less wrong
than if you think it's flat yeah but you
see the the magical illusion
of the flat earth makes it possible
for me to walk on the earth if i knew
it's spinning at dizzying speeds and
hurtling
through space and thousands of miles or
not and i knew that my body is
proportionately
as void as intergalactic space
i wouldn't have a life no not after you
get your phd from from mit with frank
after you get that no more worries no
neuroscience you would i mean
you can perfectly well get around and i
think
these scientific insights about the
world
spinning around and moving add to our
understanding of reality they don't
replace or void
our working models of how to get around
in the world that we construct as babies
they add to it and add to it with the
answer
and my mission my mission in
fundamentals is to expand
people's minds not not to completely
feed anything
grateful to you for that but i also
believe
that what we call physical matter and
the world of perceptions
is a magical life period
it's a very workable and interesting
magical life but we need a part two
because i'm late for dinner i'm gonna
bring a bottle of skype
chromium the gentleman everyone
listening to us
dr um he's a very humble person
he could have named the annual the will
check particles but he didn't
okay so i'm grateful to you sir for your
humility
leonard for being so open to these
conversations
and brian for bringing us together and
all these wonderful meetings we've had
with
mr roger penrose stewart hameroff and
all these
great people who are bringing us
closer to truth